they dance they flail they're a big
wacky and awkward way to get your
attention but did you know these tall
boys debuted at the 1996 Olympics as art
meet Peterman Shaw a prominent Caribbean
artist known in Trinidad as the creator
of larger than life dancing puppets
created for Carnival his work made its
way to a book called Caribbean festival
arts and that book made its way to a man
a man on the steering committee of the
Olympics
Peter was commissioned to help create an
unforgettable opening for the 1996
Olympic Games in Atlanta in a moment
nothing short of pure genius Peter
returned to his roots by sketching a
puppet like structure but this time he
turned it into an inflatable air man
that would move and dance just like his
mand puppets for this he had to call in
another artist their own Gazette an
engineer who happened to be obsessed
with anything inflatable between both
men they were able to accomplish the
seemingly impossible 60 foot inflatable
two-legged dancing men the tall boys
were nothing short of a success after
they graced the Olympics Kazee got a
patent and license the design to various
advertisers now they're everywhere use
car Lots crop-field shopping centers you
name it so the next time you see a big
ridiculous inflated tall boy waving at
you in the distance just imagine you're
in the Caribbean dancing along to the
drum
you know this riff it's the song
American woman originally created by
this guy hi my name is Randy Bachman I'm
wishing the band would get food it was a
big hit in the 60s and became one of the
most iconic anti-war songs of the
Vietnam era when you look back in time
and go wow that absolutely changed our
life that didn't change our life it
changed everybody's life had changed the
world had changed radio but here's the
thing that song that changed radio it
wasn't born in some recording studio but
by accident live on stage in a Canadian
curling arena so it's a cold February
day in North Dakota Randy and the rest
of the guests who just crossed the
Canadian border with the intention of
playing a show down in Texas while
filling up their truck at a local gas
station a u.s. Border Patrol officer was
calling out to them you're seeing a boy
you got to go into that building or
there boy you got are going to do
something and it was some sort of
service building I'm not sure what he
was saying because of their green cards
the officer was telling them to enter
the Selective Service building to be
drafted and sent to Vietnam so we were
like terribly frightened we got into her
car drove a couple hundred miles back to
Canada and we're in Canada without a gig
so Randy made a call to a booking agency
and because of a last-minute
cancellation he was able to find a gig
at a curling arena in water and we were
playing a three-hour dance and in the
middle of one song I broke a string and
their lead singer Burton Cummings said
well Randy's broken a string we don't
have a spirit our he's going to change
the string so we're going to take a
break so everybody was kind of sitting
around talking so I had to get that
guitar in tune so as I was onstage
playing that ecord I play an E chord
Abby corded D chord and a never Ecore
with the strings ringing and suddenly I
get done son Duda that event of them
instead of other than just
and I go oh my god I don't want to
forget this rich if I stand up and I
start playing and I turn my guitar I'm
playing it louder and I look into the
audience and came running up was Burton
Cummings finally I yelled up sing
something seeing anything first thing
he's saying was
America
miss Anne glass
when you're a songwriter you hope for
inspiration from somewhere you don't
know where it's going to come from you
don't know how minuscule or how gigantic
that little moment is going to be take
that little inspiration and put some dry
fuel on it some dry paper and see if you
can build a bonfire you never really
know where it's going to come from you
never know how far it is going to go
where it's going to take you this is
Charlie Hall hi I'm Charlie Hall this is
Charlie halls kitchen I make a fabulous
government office this is where Charlie
Hall sleeps this is it the water bed and
that bed is the whole reason we're here
it's sensuous it's like taking your bed
to bed with you Charlie Hall invented
water bends I I currently own three
water beds Charlie created a
countercultural alternative back in the
70s remember the 70s and fern bars it
was like for the groovy people right
you're too young for fern bars in the
80s they were as mainstream as they can
get you could walk into any store in
America and buy a waterbed how girly is
that at their peak more than one in five
of the beds sold in the United States
were filled with water but it all
started with a novel idea Charlie had
when he was in grad school in the late
60s he had an assignment to analyze and
improve human comfort so I talked to
physical therapists and doctors and a
whirlpool bath came up as a frequently
mentioned item about soothing
temperature and water Charlie's first
prototype was a chair filled with jello
but there was a problem that was a three
hundred pounds and not terribly
practical around your living room
although she had a forklift so Charlie
switched gears and focused on beds the
bed evolved into a water-filled chamber
I discovered very quickly you needed to
compensate for the temperature so he
added temperature control
when he should the assignment to the
class everybody loved it and they
couldn't get enough of it and guess what
Charlie got a name the original water
bed patent I applied for a patent
shortly after I developed the product
and I got a sense it was going to be a
success charlie is still a
self-proclaimed water man
this is Charlie's view this is his boat
and this is Charlie with his latest
invention
inflatable kayaks that store in the
trunk of your car and paddle like a real
nice boat okay that's great back to
water bits the Second Coming is upon us
the new version will follow the old
water bed of the water
pun intended yes one intended
little trees there a rearview mirrors
staple protecting noses from offensive
odors all over the world but where do
they come from over 60 years ago a
scientist by the name of Julius Amon had
a chance encounter with a milkman that
changed the course of the air freshener
game forever it was in Watertown New
York a milkman was making the rounds
when he stopped to speak to Julius a
German Jewish chemist who fled the Nazis
and studied out buying tree aromas in
the forests of Canada said milkman began
venting to Julius about the stench that
spoiled milk left in his car and thus
the quest began to destroy bad car odors
Julius drew inspiration from the tree
aromas he studied by infusing their oils
onto paper in 1954 he filed a patent for
tree shaped paper infused with odor
destroying air perfume
Julius then started producing the air
fresheners out of an empty auto shop and
sending samples to local gas stations
the little trees were a big hit and
Julius successfully created the first
automotive air freshener though the look
remains the same the scents are forever
changing now the little tree company has
over 60 cents and has sold over a
billion little trees worldwide
without Abraham Lincoln and really his
beard Milton Bradley the godfather of
board games would have never existed
bold statement I know but let me explain
the game of life the spinner the cars
the choices college or career kids or no
kids lawyer or farmer this family game
nights staple was once a pretty morbid
game back in the 1800s Milton Bradley
was in the lithograph business following
the Republican National Convention of
1860 Bradley printed thousands of images
of Abraham Lincoln who was clean-shaven
at the time shortly thereafter Lincoln
debuted his iconic beard rendering all
of Bradley's prints worthless his
lithograph business went belly-up
so Bradley was forced to try something
new he came up with a board game a
seemingly dark and twisted board game
appropriately named the checkered game
of life the game functioned in a similar
way to how it does now
there was a spinner colored circles that
moved around the board and of course
squares that could either make you or
break you the squares on the original
game were overwhelmingly grim boasting
actions like disgrace poverty ruin crime
prison and well suicide regardless the
game flew off the shelves kids loved it
and Milton Bradley went on to own family
game night fast forward to about a
hundred years later they revamped the
game trading Bradley's morbid squares
for the more delightful ones like pay
day or graduation which we have all come
to know and love and so there you have
it the story of the game called life
thanks Lincoln